so element and Pentium that's the
element 115 is in the same group of the
periodic table as nitrogen and
phosphorus antimony arsenic and so it we
can even without knowing or seeing a
real sample we can tell quite a lot
about what the chemistry might be like
this is after all what's Mendeleev
strength for the periodic table was that
he looked where there were holes in the
periodic table where he reckoned there
should be elements and he predicted
their properties so that we can tell
that this element
UUP is going to be in some ways like the
elements in the group 15 group 15 here
if you can look is the one that is
nitrogen phosphorus arsenic antimony and
bismuth and it will be down here I until
recently i used to lecture on group 15
and i mentioned when this UUP had been
discovered i set a little exam question
and asked the students which group it
would be in thinking that they would
have to count it and not realizing that
the exam paper had a periodic table with
it marked in the right place so they got
some marks for free